But,
uh,
the advantage of talking to you even
on an inconvenient day is Diocletian.
Uh,
we don't use terms in the professional
world of history like awesome,
very much,
but the guys certainly deserves that.
He rescued the Roman empire and we'll
begin by saying what he rescued it from a,
as a preliminary,
the sections are meeting this week.
If you're wait listed for a
session section, just go to it. Um,
we will have enough sections for however
many people take this course, right?
So they're currently for the additional
ones were that were added since last
week, uh, are, um,
Wednesday at two 30 and Thursday at seven.
And again, if you're
waitlisted, just go, we'll,
we'll figure this out there. There
will be enough sections for everybody.
So,
um,
I referred last time to
the third century crisis,
the crisis of the Roman Empire that
proceeded the accession of Diocletian from
two 35 to two 84 and we mentioned several
interrelated weaknesses of the empire
that might be seen as longterm
causes of this crisis.
Um,
a the size of the empire,
it's sheer massive size.
The problem of succession.
That is, it was never quite clear and
we'll talk about this in more detail.
Um,
how one emperor succeeded another,
the urban rural imbalance.
This was a,
an empire built on cities
and to some extent,
although heavily debated among
historians to what extent,
but to some extent the cities may be said
to have drained off the energy or been
parasites on the productivity
of the countryside.
Uh,
it was an empire that was um,
according to one point of view,
more cosmopolitan than it had been
according to another point of view.
More barbarian.
In other words,
this was an empire who's Roman
population was less dominant,
partly through its own success
in coopting other peoples,
some of the peoples that had co-opted,
we're not actually originally inhabitants
of the empire particularly this is
visible in the army's which
tended to be staffed by uh,
uh,
so called barbarian tribes,
so called by the Romans who
refer to them as barbarians.
Okay.
Another problem is the east West imbalance
where the east tends to do better
economically and demographically
them the west demographically meaning
population.
We live in a world when one of the
great threats is overpopulation.
It is therefore not self evident,
although true that for most of the time
historically most places have trouble
reproducing their population.
And indeed we are starting to enter into
a period of great demographic decline.
Okay.
The infant mortality,
the low life expectancy,
the death of women in childbirth,
the prevalence of disease and to some
extent military threats of invasion,
uh, or not threats. The reality, um,
made it hard for one generation to
produce children to replace itself.
And this is true up until
the dawn of Moderna team.
So these are fundamental
problems of the Roman empire.
The real question is why do they
explode in the third century?
And this is a question as I think I
said last week with any great empire,
it's easy to point to the flaws in,
uh,
a a complicated system.
Often size is one of them.
Often bureaucracy,
often overspending on the military.
But uh,
some of these go on for a very long time,
more or less successive successfully.
Despite the flaws in the Roman
empire went on longer than most.
As we said,
the immediate problems
that explode in the third century are
invasions and succession invasions.
By first of all,
Persia.
Persia is the old enemy of
the Roman Empire. Indeed,
as many of you know,
uh,
the old enemy of the Greek city states
that proceed the Roman empire as far back
as a, the first historian
of the western tradition.
Hurghada tests,
first week of directed studies.
For those of you who are
nostalgic for that experience,
Persia is the enemy.
Now,
we never study persh as kind
of like offstage all the time.
And that's the great benefit of the
Department of Near Eastern Languages and
cultures. Uh, um,
if you want to learn about Persia
really from within, instead of as,
oh my God, the, and you know,
oh my God, the Persians in, uh,
three 70 BC and it's going to be a,
it's going to come to an end.
It is going to come to an end
in the seventh century. Uh,
but that's because of
Islam just to anticipate.
But in the third century,
Persian, it becomes research.
And having been rather passive,
it has this frontier with the
Roman Empire in the east. Um,
more or less buffer states
are Mesopotamia present day,
Iraq and Armenia.
It was not exactly the same as
the present day state of Armenia,
but more like eastern Turkey.
The dynasty that the controls Persia
and that is more aggressive than its
predecessor are the assassinations.
And this appears in your
reading, the assassin had
dynasty, the rulers of Persia,
just more aggressive and more adventurous
beginning in two 24. Uh, they,
um,
uh,
start to probe that frontier along the
Armenian and Mesopotamian border and
eventually cross it and start to wreak
havoc in some of the eastern provinces of
the Roman Empire.
The climax of this is
the emperor of Valerian,
um,
was captured by the Persians into 60
Valerian actually one of the longer a
reigning emperors of this chaotic
period. Two 53 to two 60. Um,
they kept him for a little while,
displayed him in chains,
maybe flayed him. Anyway, he
died in captivity and they, they,
they did a kind of a job on him.
I think he may be.
He was flayed after he died, just
to be, just not to be too gruesome,
but I think they displayed the skin. Uh,
as I said, I'm not a Persian specialist,
but, um, uh,
the second invasion is across the Danube,
Ryan frontier,
the Danube,
the Rhine form what the Romans thought
of as a natural frontier with the
barbarian states. That didn't mean
that they didn't cross them. In fact,
uh, many of their great, uh, uh, uh,
fortresses and establishment,
we're on the eastern side of the Rhine,
but they considered those as bulwarks
against a Germanic invasion across the
Rhine.
The Rhine and the Danube almost meet the
Ryan going from modern Netherlands down
to Switzerland.
And the Danube going also from Germany,
eventually Austria,
Hungary into the Black
Sea. Um, as we'll see,
Charlemagne in the early ninth century
tried to build a canal between the two of
them.
And there are actually traces of this
immense and completely unsuccessful
project and there now
is a canal between them.
So this is sort of the
frontier of the Roman Empire.
And this is the line above which
no wine grapes are grown, uh,
know olive oil is a pressed and,
uh, it's gotta be protected,
but, um, not worth conquering.
So we have pressure on the Rhine,
Danube frontiers in the third century,
and another emperor dcs
died fighting the goths in,
uh,
two 51 dcs and Valerian dyes into 60.
So the emperors are certainly
out there as leaders. Uh,
but that actually has to do with
the fact that their military guys,
and that is part of the problem.
The major problem besides
the invasions was succession.
There were, I mean, it depends
on how you count, you know,
is is someone a real emperor
or is he merely a pretender?
There are at least 30 emperors
between two 35 and two 85.
Many of them ruling four months.
Most of them being killed.
There were assassinated by the Praetorian
guard that is by their own, uh,
uh, troops. Uh,
they're killed in battle against
foreign enemies like dcs and Valerian.
They're killed in battle against
other people claiming to be emperors.
But the most common thing is they're
assassinated by their own troops.
How had Roman emperor
succeeded each other.
There were several ways. One is what
you would expect and that is dynastic,
but that's not all that common dynastic,
in other words,
families rule and the
family has recognized as a
ruling family and therefore,
um, uh, they, uh, uh,
echoes from father to son or if
there's no sun father to person,
daughter marries or father to nephew,
something like that.
But that was not actually so common.
Um,
sometimes, uh, the um, uh,
the next emperor was
chosen by his predecessor.
This is characteristic of the century,
second century ID,
the era of the so called good emperors.
In theory,
this is a great system.
You have no family prejudice.
You simply as a good emperor pic,
someone who looks to you like
he's going to be a good emperor.
Yeah.
So that is another possibility.
Um,
another possibility is some guy is
powerful and uses his troops to take over.
And that's what we see
in the third century.
We see only the militarization
of the empire, but the,
uh,
interference of the army in
succeed in raising a successors,
in raising a new emperors.
The army was able to make and unmake
emperors just as in some countries with
unstable political structures,
the military is able to
make and unmake rulers.
What is interesting about the third
century is that they're able to do it far
from Rome.
Some of these armies are in North Africa,
some of them are on the
frontier fighting the Persians.
Rome is becoming less and less relevant
as the dominant city of the empire.
And I mentioned that now
because we'll see on Wednesday,
the result of this is will be the
establishment of another capital,
a second capitol in the east in
what would be called Constantinople.
Modern Istanbul.
Rome is four to five for the first time.
There is a wall that you can still
see in many parts of Rome built by the
emperor or religion in two 71.
And this is a significant thing because
until [inaudible] 71, four centuries,
Rome had not been walled
because it was not threatened.
Fortification of two 71 starts to
indicate things to come or at least things
that we know are to come.
Namely Barbarian Invasions.
Just as the
marginalization of Rome,
uh,
begins at this time.
Rome in the third century is ruled,
if one can call it that by
a succession of generals,
not members of an upper class elite,
but men who have come from the provinces,
men who are not
particularly well educated,
who would have trouble recognizing
a tag, uh, from Horace.
Uh, there being no internet
just to look these quotes up.
Um, they hold the traditional
Roman elite in contempt.
The Senate of Rome is the
embodiment of that elite.
The Roman Senate is a collection of
extremely wealthy people with from good
families,
extensive property and very,
very fine education.
The people leading in the third century
now our generals raised by their troops.
One of the reasons that the troops both
raised up generals and then killed them
was that they tend to, to get a
kind of reward from the new emperor.
A thing called a donative donative is
money that you get when there's a new
emperor,
a bad idea from the point of view of
the emperor's because it encourages, um,
you know, double dipping or
triple dipping, you know, okay,
now we've gotten our money from this guy,
let's kill him and get
money from another guy.
That's don't think that's too cynical to
say that that is some of what is going
on now of all the crises
of the third century.
This is the one that leaves
the most visible impression.
There's absolutely no doubt that there
are all of these different emperors and
that the top of the
government is unstable.
The question is how much does that carry
over into the lives of ordinary people?
One measure of the effectiveness of a
civilization is that it survives and even
people don't comment very
much on political instability.
Uh, in a way, uh,
we are testing that now for many people.
The fact that the government is polarized,
it doesn't really matter in
terms of their everyday life.
How long can that go on?
That's partly because all courts
sorts of institutions, uh,
are functioning perfectly fine. Here
we are, we're meeting, you know,
there's a,
there's no a problem of the
supply of water suddenly or, um,
uh, you know, scarce
provisioning or, uh, you know,
barbarians mast outside and we'd have
to sort of protect against during our
class. It hasn't come to that, uh, uh,
yet. Uh, but, um,
if you look at the lives of ordinary
people in the third century,
they are not saying,
uh, not another emperor.
I can't take it anymore.
They're just the philosopher
Plotinus for example,
one of the great intellectual
figures of this time. Now it's true.
He has a very other worldly
way of thinking about things.
He is a follower of Plato is the leading
so called neoplatonist philosopher
flourishes during the third
century, travels a bit. Uh,
but we never hear of any difficulty,
any kind of problems raised
by these unstable conditions.
The one that might have affected more
people than the instability is inflation.
Roman coinage was silver and bronze.
And based on ratios of
these metals to gold,
ultimate standard of value was gold,
but bronze and silver had attributed
values in relation to gold.
Been need to reward the army with those
donative and the dislocations of the
invasions led to tremendous
government expenditures.
And this was a society that
did not have debt financing.
There are no bonds, there are
no ways of the government, uh,
anticipating future revenues and
borrowing money against them.
That is actually an invention of the
middle ages was an example of something
that the Romans didn't have that
medieval cities in Italy pioneered debt
financing.
I don't have to tell you what that is
and it's a great advantage up to a point,
great up advantage because
it gives you leverage,
allows you to do things now.
So,
um,
how does a government deal with problems
like this? If it can't borrow money,
it does what is called debasing.
The coin it
okay
to debase that is degrade the coin and
means that you just don't put in as much
silver or bronze,
let alone cold and try to get
people to accept it for its value.
Anyway.
So up until the 1970s,
the American currency was based on gold
and dollar bills were called silver
certificates.
They said that you could hand this
bill in for a dollar's worth of silver.
It was technically speaking,
not currency.
It was merely a representative of
currency which you could trade in.
And before that,
of course the coins were metal dollars
were both silver and paper with the
silver one being in some
sense the more real, um,
it is in the nature of modern government
financing that at some point the
government could just say forget about it.
And even long before the 19 seven days,
uh,
of course the government
didn't have enough silver
for everyone to trade them in
just as it doesn't have enough gold in
Fort Knox to float the entire world's
currency. It has a law and
that's important, you know,
that there'd be some real kind
of value or bullion or you know,
bottom line kind of gold
bars. But, uh, uh, uh,
the fact that it's not enough
is not intrinsically a problem.
But here the government say the government
receives a thousand receives in the
form of taxes. And stuff.
Uh, a thousand gold units,
uh,
and it issues 2000 units using that gold.
The coins say they're worth a,
a unit,
but they're actually in terms of
precious metal value worth a half.
So it pays its expenses
that way it pays the army,
it gets people to accept this money.
But when those people
go to buy stuff or uh,
they are going to find
that the stuff is 50% more
because their coins are
not actually very good.
But governments tend to do this gradually
hoping that people don't notice in the
first place or that if
the inflation is say 10%,
it's not so bad. But once having embarked
on the debasement of the coinage,
this tends to get out of control because
of the famous Gresham's law in 18th
century economist that
bad money drives out good.
If I have good a sister ses or Roman
currency with the full measure of silver
that they say they have one full unit and
I've got other coins that say one full
unit but only have half,
I'm going to try to get rid of the bad
ones and horde the good ones and only
spend the good ones if I absolutely
have to or demand a premium on them.
So therefore there are all these crappy
coins circulating like mad and the good
ones a retreat into people's,
uh,
well they don't really have
mattresses then, but you know,
into their store boxes or under their
beds creating in itself more and more
inflation.
So you have a fierce and
flesh and prices go up.
People don't know the value of
things. They start bartering. Uh,
and the Roman economy is very,
very adversely effected as
hyperinflation tends to.
And um,
uh,
a final problem is the
ruin of the local elite,
um,
partly because of this economic chaos,
but partly from deeper causes.
The importance of,
this is something that I alluded to last
time in that is that the emperor empire
could not be held together
really by the government.
However big the government was,
it required the cooperation of wealthy
people with ties to their native city.
It was these people who sponsored games,
civic improvements,
maintain the temples and
kept a kind of local order.
The third century crisis
undermines this elite.
This elite is undermined by
the militarization of society.
They are to some extent ruined by
taxation and increased taxation.
They're just powerful
enough to be well off,
but not powerful enough to evade taxation.
But they also tend to be undermined
by an empire that's more cosmopolitan,
where local elites don't matter
as much. Where, for example,
military people who move around
a lot are more important.
And I emphasize this not only because of
these elites themselves and their role
in holding the empire together,
but we're going to talk about this when
we talk about Christianity because when
the local elites are ruined,
so his local religion and local
religion means polytheism.
If I am of a grand family of,
uh,
let's say the city of Sardis in Asia,
minor modern Turkey,
and I feel that my ancestors have always
been involved in the worship of the
goddess Sibley,
and I am a voter re or you know,
officer or you know,
I come member of the governing board of
the club or society that runs the cult
of Sibley.
I'm going to feel very local,
very loyal to that local deity.
But if I come from North Africa and I'm
in Sardis because that's where my army
is a, I'm not going to care
about some local no more than,
uh, you know, you might
care about, um, uh,
you know,
a club that's important at Yale.
If you went to the University of Illinois,
no more important than you might feel,
uh,
about pizza in new
haven. If, uh, you know,
you came from somewhere else and
didn't like the pizza. It's just,
it's just like this local cult and,
and you know,
you don't understand
it and you don't care.
So the kind of things you will care about,
we'll see religiously, but they will
tend to be religions that cross borders,
like Christianity,
religions that are not identified with
one place and one God in the sense of
local God, local temple. My people.
So into this mess Diocletian
you've got high cliche defeats.
His predecessor Karina us in battle in
two 84 Diocletian as a general into 84 it
would have seemed like more of the same,
but Diocletian rules until
three Oh five and he abdicates,
he passes the power to someone else.
He is, however, very typical of
the military class of the empire.
He came from nowhere socially.
He was the son of an
ex slave from Dalmatia,
modern coastal Croatia.
You can still see his palace in the
Croatian city of Split on the Adriatic.
His retirement palace,
actually
under his severe guidance,
the empire was reformed and the way it
was reformed was that it was ineffective.
Militarized Diocletian
was Donna, great general,
but he was a brilliant manager and he
was a brilliant bureaucratic organizer.
I use the term bureaucracy,
not too mean inefficient,
useless administration,
but administration,
administration,
officers of the state who are capable
of doing their jobs or maybe not capable
of doing their jobs,
but who are nevertheless,
I'm not making a value judgment
with the term bureaucracy.
I simply mean the proliferation of
government and government offices.
Diocletian is,
uh,
responsible for the militarization of
society that is building society around
the army in order to protect it.
And he is responsible for a more efficient
and ultimately burdened some form of
taxation.
The two are linked because as we know,
you have to pay to have a
large and effective military.
Diocletian did not set out to be a
revolutionary. His aims were conservative.
He wanted to save,
preserve,
restore the Roman empire of the pre two 35
era.
His methods were radical.
He was willing to
undertake radical measures
and the debate among
historians now somewhat muted.
Many historians at one time felt that
he had basically destroyed the empire.
That by making it so bureaucratic,
so militarized,
so heavy handed in terms of government,
it no longer was the Roman empire.
It was something else.
Yeah.
The reason this is no longer exactly a
considered to be a big problem or a big
controversy.
You'll see when we come to read Wickham,
the Empire has an impress on society.
There is what he calls
the burden of empire,
but it is at the same time
not a totalitarian empire
that controls everything.
Uh, society has an identity that's
different from the government.
Yeah.
So he has three goals.
One,
solving this problem of the imperial
succession to stabilizing the economy.
Three,
protecting the frontiers
of these three is actually only
really successful in the third,
protecting the frontiers.
He devises a system that we're going to
talk about in a moment of succession,
but it does not really
outlast him very long.
The economy does get fixed,
but not the way,
not exactly because of his policies.
What he's really successful at and
what changes most dramatically is what
rulership means.
That includes the figure of the emperor
who becomes more sacred and more
powerful in terms of imagery
as well as administration
changes in the administration
of taxes in particular,
and then that a goal of his to
change and grow the military.
The size of the army grew probably doubled
maybe just as a ballpark figure from
200,000 troops to 400,000 troops.
This is a major,
major increase that had to be paid for
and it had to be paid for by taxation and
from a population not particularly
eager to volunteer to pay more.
Ultimately it looks as if Diocletian
didn't so much increased taxation as
increased the efficiency
of its collection.
In order to increase the
efficiency of his collection,
he had to increase the bureaucracy
charged with monitoring the taxes and that
means first making an
inventory of taxable resources.
There is no income tax in this society
because it's an economy based more on
land than on salaries,
so you have an income tax is easy
because you can keep records
of what people are earning.
The government to this day finds it much
easier to take a portion of your wages
because it knows from your
company what you're being paid.
If you're being paid in some
other form like you're a waiter
and a lot of your money is in tips,
that's harder for the government.
If your wealth is in property,
it's hard to put a value on that.
You own estates.
You have people who are free tenants who
rent land from you and pay you in money
or produce or labor. You
have some slaves. Uh,
you have a, uh, watermill um,
how do you pay taxes on all of this stuff?
The opportunities for evasion are greater.
So the first bureaucratic task was just
to have a lot of people who could value
things, who could come into
a territory and say, okay,
this farm is worth so much
and it has these many people.
They develop a system to evaluate
productive units of things like land and
population and to tax them
according to a formula.
So I have a lot of land,
but it's not very good land.
I have a lot of people
making a living off it.
I will be taxed at a lower rate than
someone who has maybe half that land,
but twice the people better soil,
uh, um, more clearance of forests,
whatever the reason
it changes.
So every 15 years the government
changes its estimation.
A second means once you have this
taxation system in place of bringing the
empire together and dominating it more
is to have the army really have a first
call on the resources of the state.
We now start to have a state
supply system for the army alone.
This allows the state to avoid
dealing with that debased currency.
So for example,
the state just goes in and takes wind
and gives it to the army without taking
money, buying weed,
giving that to the army.
Diocletian binds the empire together
also very effectively by a postal system
post in this case, meaning a
a system of riders, horses,
communications that allows the emperor
to go faster than anyone else to have
news quicker than anyone else to
send orders quicker than anyone else.
And also more punishment
for things like tax evasion.
It's not just that people get killed for
not paying their taxes or imprisoned or
tortured,
but the groups are responsible.
It's not only that, if I don't
pay my taxes, I get punished,
but if you and I live in the same
village and you don't pay your taxes,
I get punished. Or at the very least
taxed for the part that you have aided.
Yeah,
but the most important change in
government is the establishment of what's
called the tetrarchy.
Yeah.
The tetrarchy is the
rule of four four rulers.
Diocletian divides the
empire first into East West,
a very significant move that will have
consequences for the next 1200 years.
He then
appoints a co emperor
to roll in the West
while he rolls in the east.
Okay.
Mh. Mh appoint a helper
number three and number four,
the emperors,
the two emperors are called Aqua sty.
Emperors and the helpers are Caesars.
So their subordinates to
their respective August time
and they're supposed to help them.
Why this system?
This is really to overcome the
problems of size, communication,
administration.
It's a statement that the empire
is too big for one man to rule.
Okay.
But the chief emperors are also exalted.
Now.
There is no longer a pretense that
they're just first citizens or princes.
They are clothed in purple.
They are,
don't move a lot in public audiences.
And we're familiar with this kind of
dichotomy between the political figure as
distant authority versus
the political figure,
at least pretending to be just like you
and me. We're in the era of the latter,
but Diocletian Yannick period ushers
in a period when the emperor is distant
glimpsed product of ceremonies
wearing a lot of very funny looking,
but fancy clothes,
he doesn't appear a lot in public.
He's a god.
Uh,
you don't go up to him and shake hands
or say hi or you throw yourself at his
feet and don't look at
him until he tells you to.
So the tetrarchy great idea.
It really doesn't work
because first of all,
the emperors don't necessarily cooperate.
The seizures don't necessarily
cooperate with the emperors. Uh,
and um,
so in two 85 Diocletian nominates a,
um,
a uh,
Cesar and then makes them
into 86 a co Augustus.
And this man is named Max Simeon.
Okay.
In two 93 Diocletian and
Maximilian appoint to Caesar's.
I think I'm not going to burden
you with, uh, the personnel.
I will hand out something,
um,
on Wednesday that that gives
you some of this information.
Diocletian and Maximilian appoint
Gillary areas in the east,
in Constantia constantness in the west.
You don't have to remember who these are.
And each of them marries a daughter
of their respective Augusta.
This looks like a great system.
Okay.
In three Oh five,
Diocletian and Maximilian abdicate.
And then these two people become August,
died to Caesars,
rise up to be August time and they
appoint their own new Caesar's.
It breaks down beginning in three of six,
one of the sons of one of these,
Augusta is not appointed
and he's mad and he revolts.
And then the, um, August
I'd dunk get along, uh,
out of this chaos between
three Oh six and three,
12 emerges one emperor
and that is constant team.
And we'll be talking about
Constantine, uh, on Wednesday.
So the tetrarchy fails.
Diocletian's second big initiative was
over this question of the economy and
ways of combating inflation.
Diocletian issued a so
called edict on prices.
The edict on prices attempted
to set a fixed price for goods.
And if you sold them for more than that,
you were to be severely punished.
This is the kind of the classic example
of the state trying to combat inflation
by dictating prices.
Most of you are not familiar
with inflation but it is
because we have lived in
an era of very low interest
and a fairly stable prices,
but if you think of those commodities
who's inflation you are familiar with like
petroleum,
it is very dislocating.
It starts to create panics and the
panics then feed into the inflation.
Just as if people keep on getting gas
because they think that it's going to go
up in price.
Then there's a greater demand for
gasoline and it goes up further in price
eventually.
If the thing is really just speculative,
it deflates again and that's what's
happened with products that we're familiar
with in recent times,
but there is also a kind
of structural long term,
longer term inflation such as
America experience. For example,
in the 70s and in theory if you have
resource crises and things that are
becoming scarcer than you ought to have
more and more experience with inflation.
The government in the 1970s in the United
States tried also to have an edict on
prices. Uh, under President
Ford, there was a, uh, kind of,
uh, uh, administration of maximum prices.
The problem with this is that it
creates a temptation for black markets.
Creates a version of what we were just
talking about with Gresham's law of
coinage.
If you say that tomatoes can only be
sold for a dollar a pound than those
tomatoes that are being sold for a
dollar a pound in a climate of severe
inflation will be terrible,
will be rotten.
If you want to pay $2 a pound in secret,
we have some nice tomatoes for you.
And if you want to pay $5 a pound,
we have some really nice, you
know, uh, uh, locally grown, um,
uh, tomatoes for you, all
of which may be illegal,
but the legal market is empty.
And this is what happened in a response
to the edict of Pri with of prices.
This doesn't mean that the government
cannot still remains debatable,
obviously the degree to which government
can or cannot intervene in such things.
But certainly in the case of
the Roman Empire, this failed.
What did bring back a measure of
economic stability is the reform of the
taxation.
The fact that the state simply started
getting in more resources that les was
being withheld by private people.
And so the state could actually pay for
its administrative and military costs.
Diocletian succeeded in
abdicating, peacefully spent, uh,
his retirement in split in his palace
and live to see the breakdown or the
partial breakdown of the tetrarchy.
And in certain respects,
his policies clearly failed.
The edict on prices had to be
abandoned. The tetrarchy, uh,
did not work.
Okay.
And Diocletian failed in trying
to suppress Christianity.
We'll talk about this some more, but
Diocletian in the late part of his reign,
you know, a couple of animals were split
open to see what the future would be.
Um, right. Isn't that what
we all do? Uh, uh, uh,
you know, if you want to figure out
kind of what's going to happen, you,
you slaughter an animal, an animal,
and, and, and check out. It's liver.
Maybe it's kidneys and spleen too,
but the liver is really which
you want to look at. And um,
I don't exactly know what the animal was,
what the organs were and why
they didn't splay out. Right.
But the liver told Diocletian that the
Christians were responsible for this and
that he'd better go after them.
So there is this big persecution of
Christians in the first part of the fourth
century. Um, and uh, he
certainly didn't succeed in that.
Not only did the Christians not crumble,
but of course Diocletian's most effective
successor six years after he abdicated
would convert to Christianity.
But Diocletian is extremely
important and in many respects,
extremely successful.
He did more than prop
up a tottering empire.
Okay.
He did more than just transform a
tottering empire into a kind of tottering
tyranny.
He saved the Roman Empire.
He saved the Roman Empire
for a hundred years.
When you take a course like this
that goes for 700, 800 years,
you start to hurl centuries around,
uh, and get confused above them.
But any polity that exists for a hundred
years is fairly impressive or a policy
that looks like it's about to collapse
and then is restored for a hundred years.
Okay.
The Roman Empire,
conventionally speaking,
is thought to have collapsed in
the West in the late fifth century
in the east.
However,
arguably Diocletian's reforms last
for more on the order of 1200 years.
The eastern empire,
the Byzantine Empire would fall in 1453
and two its last day it was modeled on
Diocletian panic,
administrative and military forms.
People at the time clearly thought
that they'd been saved from disaster.
If you look at fourth century artifacts,
things like mosaics on the
floors of dining rooms,
people often put mottos there and their
mottoes or things like joyful times
everywhere or a world restored.
The fourth century is interpretable as
an era of increasing gloom because we
know that in the fifth century
things are going to collapse,
but people in the fourth century
are not saying to each other,
I'm so glad I'm alive in the fourth
century cause I don't want to see what's
going to happen in the fifth.
They're just happy that the barbarians
are back across the Danube and the Rhine.
The Persians are more or less
controlled along the frontier.
Yes, taxes are high. Yes,
the elite is sort of a riff raff and
not as well educated and their military
people.
Basically things are working.
Prosperity is restored to the people
who had been prosperous before.
You know, the local elites
have declined, but uh,
it's not so visible as it had been.
But there are some changes.
Changes that we can with the
proverbial benefit of hindsight.
See changes in the center of gravity.
The dominant places are now
places that are military basis.
They are great cities with
all the amenities of Rome.
That is stadiums,
gateways.
One of the best preserved of these
to this day is trickier in Germany.
On the Moselle.
Behind the Rhine has a wonderful
collection of Roman ruins,
a gateway. The port and I grew up, uh, uh,
eight um,
theater,
a sports arena,
a basilica,
a law court turned into a church.
The reason or was great was
because of the frontier.
There was one of the most important cities
in the empire because of the military,
because its strategic importance. And
there are other cities that are like this.
Milan,
for example,
becomes more important than Rome
because Milan is further north.
It's a good place to get to the
Daniel van to the Rhine quickly,
whereas Rome is buried
in the Mediterranean.
So we're in a new world.
We'll discuss more of the new world on
Wednesday and we will see the Constantine
in some cases,
completely revolutionizes things,
and in other cases
continues Diocletian's work.